Come on Groot! Groot ruined Christmas again.
Now we gotta have another special.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. This will be my Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special post credits scene
and video for the ending of the movie there's a
lot of Easter eggs and references for the events
of Guardians of the Galaxy 3 in the trailer that
they just released and they pay off a bunch of
long-running Easter eggs and references from
earlier Marvel movies so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos my full breakdown video Easter eggs
for the entire holiday special will post real soon
too so be sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss that but the whole idea here is
that this is Marvel doing their version of the
Star Wars holiday special with the Guardians
of the Galaxy characters and as they say in
the post-credits scene we'll have to do another
special it's just them saying that they're going
to be doing holiday specials on a regular basis
one-off specials on a regular basis but at the end
of the special Peter Quill reveals what that first
Christmas with yondu and the ravagers kragland was
like because part of the joke at the beginning
is that the Guardians of the Galaxy have no real
idea what Christmas is they just know stories
about it that Cracklin told them but it's like
a telephone game situation where the information
is passed through so many hands that it's this
complete misconception about what actually happens
during Christmas they have all these jokes about
the other aliens like the Old 97's band that are
dressed as aliens not understanding Santa Claus
her man's demise so at the very end after Kevin
Bacon performs the original song it's an original
Christmas song that James Gunn wrote with the
old 97s Peter Quill reveals the rest of the
story of that original Christmas like oh no no it
didn't end badly yondu might have been a grinch
at first but he actually warmed up to it yondu
goes to the trash where Peter Quill put all the
presents in the tree that he had put up there's a
taser face reference because you remember that he
was a regular ravager for a long time before
he rebelled during the events regarding this
galaxy 2 which obviously funny in this context
because eventually yondu is going to kill him and
we find out the gift that Peter Quill gave him
is actually the toy that we saw in the dash in
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie into the
second movie it is just a way to show you what
their relationship was like like he really was his
surrogate father yondu having it all those years
later even though he was really mad at Peter Quill
during that first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
still thinks of him as his son and we find out
that yondu's gift to him were the twin blasters
that has been using this whole time in the MCU
through all the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
Avengers Infinity War Avengers endgame Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 and mantis reveals the truth to
Peter Quill about being his half-sister so if
you didn't realize this they actually explained
this during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 James Gunn
was talking about it but I think because a lot
was going on during that movie people just didn't
think about that specifically they had that funny
Montage during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 where
ego The Living Planet shows this diorama of him
getting it on with pretty much the entire universe
trying to sire a child that he'll be able to use
to take over the universe and the idea is that
most of them were failures he wound up killing
them putting him in this pile there but the
reason why mantis wasn't killed is because her
powers were useful even though he wasn't able to
use her to take over the universe the way he used
Peter Quill's energy and if it wasn't clear the
whole idea is that Peter Quill is still half a
Celestial mantis now confirmed half Celestial but
his special Celestial power only existed when he
was in contact or near ego The Living Planet and
when he was alive I know there are all kinds of
theories about ego The Living Planet secretly
being alive out there in the MCU but I think
within the 616 MCU he's supposed to be dead so if
we do see ego come back it'd be like a secret Wars
Multiverse kind of twist I know there's still
tons of questions about ego the living planet's
relationship with the other celestials like Irish
and the judge but if you remember he's meant to be
a rogue Celestial his whole plan is very similar
to what the other celestials were trying to do
Seed Life all across the universe experiment with
life ego The Living Planet was trying to do the
same thing it was just a very perverted version
of that you do kind of Wonder though why the other
celestials didn't try to kill him though but the
big idea earlier is that mantis hadn't told Tim
before this because when it was deleted scene and
James Gunn just wanted to save it for a later big
reveal and the in Universe version is because
she was worried that Peter Quill would hate
the idea because of what ego The Living Planet
did but of course he loves the idea because now
he has a sister that he didn't know about which
obviously he loves because now his entire family
isn't dead and in the animated flashback again we
see yondu put the toy on the dashes they head off
for their next adventure with the ship making
the merry Christmas sign with the energy and if
it wasn't clear this [__] that they're flying in
is also part of the dark Aster the larger ravager
ship this was long before they blew up the other
part of the ship this was the small detachable
part that they were flying during Guardians of
the Galaxy 2. it becomes a bigger thing during
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 with gamora's character
who I'll talk about in a second because obviously
she wasn't featured during this special but in the
actual post-credit scene they have that funny tag
scene with rocket and Cosmo dressing grued up like
an actual Christmas tree because he is literally
a talking tree which he gets tired of like he
just gets tired of standing still and they claim
he's ruined Christmas again so they have to do a
whole other special which itself is meant to be
a reference to Marvel doing more holiday specials
on a regular basis they might do another Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special but I kind of think
that they're going to rotate with other teams and
characters like the next holiday special will be a
completely different group really good example of
that is the surprise Deadpool Christmas movie
that Ryan Reynolds Just revealed that he made
before Disney bought Fox recently Ryan Reynolds
explained that they wrote and prepared a secret
Deadpool movie in 2018 a couple years ago after
Deadpool 2 had been released and they were going
to release it during the Christmas season but
it got lost in the shuffle he says when Disney
bought Fox a lot of movies of all kinds that fox
was working on were canceled during that period
a couple years ago when the buyout went down not
just the fox Marvel movies they had planned but
the Deadpool Christmas movie was meant to be a
completely separate completely different movie
from the earlier version of Deadpool 3 that Ryan
Reynolds had planned to make before Disney bought
Fox which they'd already plotted out the funny
thing about that earlier version of Deadpool
3 is that it was also going to be a Deadpool
Wolverine team-up movie The Deadpool Christmas
movie would have been much smaller in scope and
it would have taken the place of Once Upon a
Deadpool which was their constellation Christmas
movie by the holidays thought it'd be fun rpg-13
it's a family movie also money also Disney but it
wasn't really a legit Christmas movie it was just
a PG-13 cut of Deadpool 2 meant to be released so
that they could earn more money families could buy
extra tickets for the younger kids that normally
wouldn't have seen Deadpool 2 because it was
rated R and they just released it during their
Christmas holiday later that same year in 2018
the plot of the Deadpool Christmas movie would
have been much more about actual Christmas like
a legit Christmas movie as in Deadpool versus
Christmas Deadpool versus Santa Claus Deadpool
Saves Christmas kind of vibe and the funny thing
about Santa Claus is that he is a legit Marvel
character he's a very powerful Omega Level
mutant he's supposed to be one of the most
powerful mutants on the planet like we talk about
mutants coming into the MCU during Marvel phase
4 Marvel Phase 5 Marvel phase six we just met
Namor inside black panther wakanda forever and
he's another mutant who's been alive for the past
500 years in the MCU and we're just learning about
him now Santa Claus being a mutant is Marvel's way
of explaining how he accomplishes all of his tasks
that he does during Christmas night bringing
toys to everyone around the world the way Ryan
Reynolds talked about his Deadpool Christmas
movie made it sound like it was like a really
huge really expensive type of movie so I actually
think that Marvel would be better off releasing
it is a holiday special one-off in some future
year like the next couple of years at some point
it's a little bit easier for Deadpool to get away
with stories like that especially the more jokey
comedic stories just because the way the character
is built and the funny thing is that David Harbor
who is now Red Guardian in the MCU he's going
to be in the Thunderbolts movie in a big way he
just made a Christmas movie in real life where
he plays a version of Santa Claus it's called
violent night so it's more of like a hardcore
Santa Claus so it just feels like they have all
the ingredients for like a really easy really fun
one-off small Deadpool holiday special Christmas
type of movie you may remember several years ago
now when they released the first Deadpool movie
because it came out in February around Valentine's
Day they spent most of that previous Christmas
holiday promoting the movie with the 12 days of
Deadpool is probably one of the best marketing
campaigns I've ever seen Guardians of the Galaxy
will pick up a little bit after this obviously the
next movie is Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 will take place a little
bit after that in the timeline this is meant to
take place during Christmas 2025 which is the same
time as Spider-Man no way home I believe those
are meant to be happening around the same time
so when he's swinging around during Christmas in
Times Square at the end of that movie this is that
Christmas because this takes place after a Thor
love and thunder and they were referencing that
during Spider-Man no way home so it was happening
around the same time and yes the memory spell that
doctor strange performed would affect them as
well like they'd forget that Peter Parker was
Spider-Man even though they're this far away it
wasn't a situation where the spell just affected
planet Earth the only people the spell would not
have affected would be people inside the quantum
realm for instance like Kang the Conqueror
the other characters that we'll meet during
Ant-Man and the Wasp quantumania when we pick
up with the events of Guardians of the Galaxy
3 though they're actually going to be finding the
version okomora who's taken over the ravagers on
the dark astorship this ship that is featured
in all those yondu flashbacks the whole idea is
that this 2014 version of Gamora went full Thanos
because she didn't experience the events of the
first couple of Guardians of the Galaxy movies
so she didn't turn against Thanos the same way
so she's meant to be a much more hardcore version
of the character that Peter Quill and the others
like nebula for instance her sister are trying to
win over to the team so even though I think that
they'll be successful in that the whole vibe
of her character will be completely different
because she's meant to be a completely different
version of the character so her relationship
with this version of nebula with this version of
Peter will be completely different than the other
version of Gamora Groot obviously going to get a
little bit bigger during Guardians of the Galaxy
3 the whole idea is that he's turning to the more
Chad full-size version of Groot but also Cosmo the
talking dog will be back in Guardians 3. that's
the whole reason why he cast her during this I
refuse to do any more work while you demand me
all right all right I'm sorry chill out also on
one of those delicious treats in that bag I've got
a bunch of other videos that I'm working on so my
full breakdown Easter eggs for the entire holiday
special will post on Saturday make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here for that video I'll update
the link as soon as I post it and everyone click
here for my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!